it's a nice country whatever they say is
not true you know we came to watch the
game to watch the soccer game the
football game but uh some people
complain about the alcohol we came to
have fun not to drink or be drunk so for
me fine before I get into what does this
actually mean
[Applause]
[Music]
rasulullah
we wanted to learn about Islam yeah we
wanted to learn and how they make made
such a leap to go ahead and connect it
to this extreme group and whatnot
they're getting really desperate I in
photos
but you can see now instead of
highlighting some of the beautiful
things that we get we got to see but
people were panicking about oh can you
drink over there or not and I saw
Senegalese fans I saw sad Arabian fans
that's what Argentinian fans having the
time of their life without alcohol and
the thing is they're able to go and do
it again because English always are in
bed hung over and tired and you think
about having in during the Euros last
time in the final the fights and that
it's really I don't know it's made me
question my relationship with alcohol a
little bit and they could have made
their connection when the Moroccan
players are prostrating down and now
they could have been like well hold on
are this they're connected to this
extreme good old group also or maybe
Jesus uh you know he he actually prayed
like this just like the Moroccan players
right then and there and he went a
little further according to the Bible
and he went he fell on his face and he
prayed to who himself no he prayed to
the creator of Heaven of the heavens and
earth God Almighty Allah so they're
prostrating giving thanks keeping it
humble you see the Moroccan players but
we have you know this it's very sad you
know that you have the the
um parents are being neglected totally
disrespected fingers you want to talk
about fingers
and you go ahead and guess what fingers
that are being given to parents nowadays
you know verbally even with the
Expressions parents are totally
disrespected and the Moroccan players
there are showing because of Islam
they're showing gratitude to the Creator
first and foremost thus the finger does
the finger I'll get back to that in a
second uh but they're going and thanking
the mother the mother is so high and
elevated in Islam there's a authentic
statement by the prophet Muhammad last
final Master sent to mankind he said
that paradise lies under the defeat of
your mother signifying respect and
compassion towards your mother you can
see that with the Moroccan players so
they forget about all this we heard a
lot of hateful ridiculous crazy comments
coming here from friends and family but
we wanted to see for ourselves the
experience the culture as well as the
football itself and we love everything
that has been on the media or Twitter
social media has been very very far off
exactly from what they did here pure
love respect for one another everyone's
helpful it's a community oriented I love
it and I definitely can see myself
coming back for sure and they jump on
this
is
and you'll see myself you'll see Habib
he's also doing this he's pointing out
many athletes we'll throw up to one
finger they won't throw the middle
finger but they'll throw up the one
finger signifying that the strength that
they get the courage that they get
the victories that we get all the good
that we get is not the chest bump but
it's to the one up above the crater of
the heavens and earth the same God that
Jesus worshiped the same God that Moses
worshiped the same God that the last and
final messenger called Humanity to
worship be thankful and grateful to the
one who gave you your eyes that you see
with the ears that you hear with
everything that you have we say look
that's
because of the one the one up above
pure this is signifying pure
monotheism
now let me just make a contrast with
something else and then we'll end it you
have some people now throwing up the
three and that signifies in Orthodox
Christianity with the serbs in
particular there's an extreme element
called the chutneys and they would go
out there and they would butcher
innocent human being men women and
children you know they were throwing up
the three and like look if a Christian
wants to go ahead and Orthodox
Christians specifically here to serbs
they want to go ahead and throw this hey
that's their religious belief even
though now this is also attributed to
this extreme group the street extreme
element that was persecuting Muslims and
these extremists but now somebody a
Christian wanted to go ahead and throw
up the Trinity that's his right he can
go ahead and do that we're not going to
go ahead and disrespect that into
individual just like this reporter and
these people now the racism is coming
out the islamophobia is kicking in and
they just can't help you know and now
they got to come up and getting
desperate now and trying to equate
something so beautiful this pure
monotheism with something so extreme so
again wrapping up this when you see a
Muslim do this this is signifying one
the pure monotheism number two it's
attributing that humbleness that
everything it's not according to us and
our strength and our power but it's to
the one up above like I mentioned
earlier when you see khabib he wouldn't
do the chest bump but he would be
pointing to the one up above and again
that is giving all thanks and praise to
the creator of the heavens and earth as
something beautiful and it's you for you
it's for everybody out there if you're
thinking what's the purpose of life why
am I here it starts with asking the one
up above Guide Me Guide Me Guide Me and
then from there you'll be probably
throwing up not the three but the one
signifying their is only one God and he
alone is worthy of all my thanks
gratitude praise and worship no one
other than him thank you very much and
that is what this stands for
assalamualaikum peace be with you we
need to do this for the future of our
children the future of our great country
the future of mankind this is your
brother and I've got a very important
message alhamdulillah brother Eddie is
setting up the dean Center not just the
dean show but the dean sent her a full
dawa Academy a Masjid a dawa Center in
America the first of its type the a
groundbreaking project and I want
everybody as I'm supporting it I want
everybody to support it so we can take
the dawah to the next level we need the
dean Center please support it foreign